I can remember when we started down the
journey
and we went on to this thing called it
think Academy IBM's longtime motto had
been think and we said okay I'm gonna
make the first Friday of every month
compulsory education
and okay I mean everybody like everybody
I don't care what your job is okay when
the whole company has to transform
everybody's got to get kind of have some
skin in this game and understand it I
taught the first hour of every month for
four years now nice okay I had to learn
something so
but it made me but I'm like okay if I
can teach
and teach that right I mean what kind of
thing so it was a compulsory uh Thursday
night education for you a little bit I'm
a little bit better prepared than that
but yes you're so right yes yeah so you
you prepare yeah
you like to prepare yeah but there's
roots in that go back deeply deeply
deeply deeply and I think it's an
interesting reason so why do why are you
you're preparer my friend yeah yes you
are you prepare for your interviews uh
sure the rest you Wing yeah I Wing but
that's okay I mean you don't have to
prepare everything I don't prepare
everything either no but I I
unfortunately Wing stuff I save it to
last minute I I push everything I'm
always almost late and I don't know why
that is I mean there's some deep
psychological thing we should probably
investigate but it's probably the
anxiety
brings out the performance that can be
that's very true with some people I mean
so I'm a programming engineer at heart
and so so programmers famously
overestimate or underestimate sorry how
long that something's going to take it's
all just everything always underestimate
and it's almost as if I want to feel
this chaos of anxiety of a deadline or
something like this otherwise I'll be
lazy sitting on a beach with a pina
colada and relaxing yeah I don't know so
that we have to know ourselves but for
you for me you like to prepare yeah it
came from a few different places I mean
one would have been as a as a kid I
think
um
I was not a memorizer and my brother is
brilliant he can he read it once boom
done and so I always wanted to
understand like how something happened
it didn't matter what it was I was doing
it whether it was algebra theorems I
always wanted don't give me the answer
don't give me the answer you know I want
to figure it out figure out so I could
reproduce it again and didn't have to
memorize so it started with that and
then over time
okay so I was in university in the 70s
when I was in engineering school I was
the only woman you know I meet people
still to this day and they're like oh I
remember you I'm like yes sorry I don't
remember you there were 30 of you wanted
me and
I I think you already get that feeling
of okay I better really study hard
because whatever I say is going to be
remembered in this class good or bad and
it started there so in some ways
I did it for two reasons early on I
think it was a shield for confidence
the more I studied the more prepared I
was the more confident that's probably
still True to this day
the the second reason I did it evolved
over time and became different to
prepare
um if I was really prepared then when
we're in the moment I can really listen
to you see because I don't have to be
doing all this stuff on the fly in my
head and I could actually take things I
know and maybe help the situation so it
really became a way that I could be
present in in the moment and I think
it's something a lot of people that in
the moment I I learned it from my
husband he doesn't prepare by the way at
all so that's not it but I watched the
in the moment the negative example no no
no and I'm not going to change that as
he says he's a type c I'm an A okay
that's how love works yeah and I have
been married 43 years and that seems to
work so but that idea that you could be
in the moment with people is a really
important thing yeah so the preparation
gives you the freedom to really be
present